extrêmement reconnaissants pour tous les
moments de joie que vous avez apporté à
tous les Français alors encore une fois
merci bravo à tous bravo à Didier
Deschamps à tous les joueurs de l'équipe
de France et allez les bleus plus que
jamais
[Applaudissements]
ils ont bravaient le froid d'une nuit
d'hiver et trouver le moyen de se
réchauffer ensemble
[Applaudissements]
les supporters français ont attendu leur
bleu
il est 21h30 environ avec une heure de
retard quand les joueurs de l'équipe de
France arrivent place de la Concorde
de quoi réchauffer des cœurs forcément
un peu triste Olivier Giroud et Antoine
Griezmann savourent et se lance dans un
clapping avec la foule
une joie qui tranche sérieusement avec
la mine grave de Kylian Mbappe
visiblement encore très affecté 15
minutes pour évacuer collectivement la
douleur d'une finale perdue mais
héroïque se projeter aussi vers l'avenir
[Applaudissements]
on les attend parce que nous on a une
grande équipe et on est là et on sera là
il y a un de mes confrères qui a laissé
son sac avec carte de crédit pas tout ce
que vous pouvez imaginer dans le métro
il va au commissariat je vous inquiétez
pas
dans une heure vous avez tout une heure
après le mec il avait tout ah non mais
c'est pas Porte de la Chapelle
vous avez complètement raison la
personne qui a essayé le masque avant
moi
devrait consulter un spécialiste
dentaire visiblement pour arrêter de
manger du brie de mots
qui a passé la date de péremption voilà
je viens
de propreté quand vous arrivez à
l'aéroport tu as pas un mégot par terre
c'est un pays très démocrate renvoyé ça
se jette finalement
c'est juste pour les ouvriers
pakistanais elles sont toutes bêtes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nouvelle victoire pour Lionel Messi
cette fois sur le terrain des réseaux
sociaux sa publication de champion du
monde et désormais le poste le plus aimé
sur Instagram avec plus de 60 millions
de like ce combat virtuel il ne l'a pas
mené contre Mbappé ni contre Cristiano
Ronaldo mais face à un adversaire plus
coréen sans corps un œuf oui une photo
de toute simple postée en 2019 dans le
seul but d'être numéro 1 ce qu'elle
était depuis trois ans avant le sacre
des argentins et de Messi beaucoup
d'Argentan finalement attendu pour rien
il y a quelques minutes 16h15 en
Argentine 20h15 en France les joueurs
sont évacués en hélicoptère
rodemonde impossible pour Red
d'atteindre la Place de l'Obélisque
sur le chemin plusieurs milliers de
supporters accueillaient les héros une
fois arrivé dans leur camp de base les
joueurs peuvent se reposer quelques
heures à l'image de Messi qui a partagé
son lit avec la Coupe du monde
ils ont donné le bonheur dont nous avons
besoin économiquement ça va tellement
mal que les hommes politiques en
prennent de la graine l'union fait la
force ensemble on y arrive on partait
perdant et on termine champion du monde
les supporters sont fous de joie
communion totale alors on voit de tout
simplement et bien sont venus à pied
de croiser les jouets
[Musique]
alors on l'entend on l'entend surtout la
fête autour de vous c'est quand même
l'histoire d'un féminicide quand même
cette chanson c'est quand même
l'histoire d'un type qui tue une meuf
par amour et ensuite qui se bute pour
rester parce que c'est quand même ça la
chanson donc est-ce qu'il y a un message
vis-à-vis de ton épouse dans ce choix de
cette chanson pas du tout pas du tout
selon les estimations des médias
argentins au moins 5 millions de
personnes se sont réunies dans les rues
de Buenos Aires pour célébrer le
troisième sacre mondial de l'Argentine
des supporters qui n'ont pas toujours la
victoire très élégante cela brandisse la
photo de Mbappé avec ces mots reposant P
tes morts pour jouer comme le grand
Lionel Messi internet a voté Elon Musk
doit quitter la présidence de Twitter le
nouveau patron du réseau social s'est
mis dans la panade tout seul en lançant
un sondage ce week-end plus de 57% des
17 millions de votants souhaite qu'il
laisse cette responsabilité à un autre
reste à savoir s'il tiendra parole et
qui pourrait prendre les sur Twitter il
y a déjà des candidats le lanceur
d'alerte Edouard Snowden tweet qui
l'accepte les paiements en Bitcoin